they called him Steppenwolf the end of
worlds he lived only to conquer millions
fell before his blade Moreau's again is
asperity news nightmare creatures who
feed on fear I think I didn't hit it off
hearing Gotham they're all over there
looking for boxes your mother boxes
I guess stepping will slip to one your
people regarding that leaves two more
breath
don't be I have no idea what's in them
weapon some kind of power they don't
contain power they are power carried
from planet to planet the mother boxes
combined to form the unity an
apocalyptic power that not only destroys
world but transforms them into the
primordial hellscape of Steppenwolf's
birth world
you should have died but we formed our
own unity Amazon's Atlanteans all the
tribes of man fought side-by-side
warriors of legend
[Music]
allies from other worlds even the guns
themselves all acted as one laying down
their lives to drive Stephanie away
[Music]
some say drove him and the disgrace of
his first retreat he swore our alliance
would crumble the darkness will cover
the earth
and that he would return when it did
left behind the mother boxes were too
dangerous to be kept together one was
entrusted to the Amazon's one to the
atlanteans both sealed and guarded in
secure strongholds the box of men was
buried in secret so that no tribe would
be tempted to use its power over another
you